[Music]
I love to have the series ended because
I think there was no way that everybody
was going to be happy so David Chase did
what made him happy which is you know
leave a lot of people talking about it
isn't that funny how many people have
said that like I understand I understand
but what actually happened you know as
if they continue to go on after the
cameras stopped but in fact they didn't
come to list
I just people want to know I have no
idea
now I'm starting to think that whatever
we saw that's the ending I don't know
what it means I don't know what we're
supposed to take from it what we saw is
what it is that makes no sense whether
that's there is no answer I'd like to
believe life went on think about don't
stop believing but I think it was very
indicative of their situation and the
reality I felt it was a great way for
David in the show like you know that's
it goodbye go home figure it out for you
so people say what happened here went up
to the charts
I don't know figured him for yourself
good element right for me when the show
ended I'm like the show ended you know
it's very I guess it's easy when you're
not like a fan to accept like for me the
show is what David chase put on paper so
when that rip do what the paper stopped
coming
that's it you know it's gone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]